good morning Hank it's Tuesday I assume
you're familiar with the famous Simpsons
newspaper headline old man yells at
cloud but it occurs to me that some
people watching this might not be
familiar with it or else might only know
it from the internet because they were
born after that episode of The Simpsons
first aired in 2002 so when you have
kids one of the phrases you start
hearing a lot is developmentally
appropriate like your pediatrician will
say that temper tantrums are
developmentally appropriate or that it's
developmentally appropriate for your kid
to refuse to eat anything other than
processed carbohydrates and that as such
it's developmentally appropriate for
your kid to engage in a complex nightly
negotiation over whether they will eat
two strawberries so as to stave off
scurvy anyway I like this phrase
developmentally appropriate and I wish
we continued to use it into adulthood so
that I could tell myself that it's
developmentally appropriate not to
understand snapchat or to genuinely
enjoy gardening or to find myself
yearning for some idealized past that
never existed it may be that I feel this
more acutely than the average person
because I've made a living trying to
write about how it feels to be young for
the last 13 years I mean I'm so old that
my career is a teenager I should add
here that getting older does not have to
mean yelling at clouds and on that front
I have wonderful models in my parents
both of whom have remained passionate
and hopeful and curious throughout their
adult lives like when I was in ninth
grade I like to listen to Nine Inch
Nails his pretty hate machine really
really loudly and one day my dad came in
and asked if he could borrow the CD and
I was like yeah but you're gonna hate it
because it's super alternative I think I
literally said alternative and then a
few days later my dad returned the CD to
me and told me that while he could live
without some of the profanity he found
the music really compelling and hoped I
didn't mind that he had gone out and
bought his own copy of the album ah is
there a better way to defang a child's
rebellion but even though I have
wonderful mentors in the field of being
middle-aged I still find myself yelling
at clouds I yell at literal clouds
because they impact the garden that God
helped me I have gotten really really
into I yell at our unknownst outrage
driven political discourse and most of
all I yell at and also I suppose with
the social internet from the time I was
14 until a few years ago the social
Internet gave me deep meaningful
relationships that I struggled to find
IRL but now it mostly makes me feel
anxious and spirally without deepening
my feeling of connectedness
I don't think that's because the
internet used to be amazing like 1994
AOL chat rooms make 2018 Twitter look
civil and sophisticated I think it's
because I've changed but if I didn't
feel an obligation to be on Twitter and
reddit in the rest I don't think I would
be and maybe I shouldn't feel an
obligation to be in virtual spaces that
feel like they make my life worse but
then the internet always pulls me back
in partly because I don't want to miss
out partly because I want to share stuff
I'm working on and books I love and
causes I care about and partly because I
feel this almost physical urge to check
check my email check Twitter check
Instagram check reddit make sure nothing
terrible has happened make sure there's
nothing new that needs my outrage err my
AWS check check check
like many people with OCD I live with
the constant urge to check the
terrifying dread that accompanies not
checking the irrational certainty that
this time checking will be important but
it feels to me at times like this
phenomena now happens across the social
order like the Internet has hacked
healthy brains and turned them into
obsessive checking machines but there
again I am an old man yelling at a cloud
forgetting that the social Internet also
facilitates conversations across borders
and other divisions and that it gives a
voice to people who otherwise wouldn't
have one and so on feeling the urge to
make grand pronouncements about what's
good for other people is probably a
developmentally appropriate symptom of
middle age but it's one worth fighting
against I don't know how you should live
what mary oliver called your one wild
and precious life i don't even know how
to live mine
but i know that i like my garden so if
i'm quiet on twitter or elsewhere know
that i'm probably here and quite content
Hank I'll see you on Friday